les prévisions monsieur le maire sont
une grotesque les unes que les autres
n'y a pas un gouvernement aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas évidemment un analyste le mans
qui s'est exactement se peut ce pour
battre honte sur la tête
en france il ya en europe d'ailleurs les
banques sont au plus mal
aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
banquiers se se couchent le soir
en croisant les doigts qui est pas
tendre la main
dites vous bien que 2008 c'était une
crisette ça n'a strictement rien à voir
on est dans quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
connue depuis des siècles et des siècles
[Musique]
farid 1024 vos arguments messieurs êtes
vous pour ou contre
avant moi je suis tout à fait pour mais
pas n'importe quel prix et il est hors
de question qu'une chance d'organiser
les jeux olympiques se transforme en une
véritable malédiction comme c'est le cas
très souvent moi je vais représenter le
contre parce que pour moi les jeux
olympiques c'est véritablement
l'expression du vieux monde c'est à dire
que qui ne prend jamais en compte la
question climatique la question sociale
la question environnementale
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer donc ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est vraiment
contrôlé au centime près jour par jour
ce budget est joué la transparence
complète tous les acteurs qu'ils soient
publics qu'ils soient privés
on a déjà un budget qui n'est pas tu
n'es pas sérieux et que oui ça veut dire
que nécessairement ça va être dépassé
paris fait beaucoup plus attention que
ses prédécesseurs aux questions vers non
seulement parce que c'est à la mode mais
aussi parce que le seuil haut c'est
quand même aperçu a senti passer le vent
du boulet
[Musique]
en france un plateau semble s'amorcer
selon le dernier bilan ce square du
directeur de la santé 987 nouveaux décès
ces dernières 24 heures dans les ehpad
et les hôpitaux un chiffre en légère
baisse tout comme celui d admission en
réanimation a au total plus de 13 mille
personnes sont décédées en france depuis
le début de la crise et avant de
s'exprimer lundi le chef de l'état
multiplie les réunion ce matin il s'est
notamment entretenu avec les partenaires
sociaux
[Musique]
lé 27 pays de l'union européenne
s'accordent sur une réponse économique
pour faire face à la crise du
coronavirus 500 milliards d'euros vont
être disponibles immédiatement pour
aider les états membres une réponse
commune qui marque un jour important
pour l'union européenne selon bruno le
maire dans le monde plus de cent mille
décès comptabilisés et plus d'un million
et demi de contaminer par le coronavirus
l' oms craint une résurgence mortelle de
la pandémie en cas de déconfinement
hâtif à les états unis restent le pays
le plus touché en nombre de cas et dans
ce contexte apple et google ont décidé
de s'allier pour le traçage numérique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france et on
débute avec le dernier bilan annoncé il
ya quelques minutes par jérôme salomon
le directeur de la santé 987 nouveaux
décès sont à déplorer lors des dernières
24 heures portant le total à 13 milles
197 décès dans les hôpitaux et dans les
ehpad plus de 7000 personnes se trouvent
actuellement en réanimation à des
chiffres en baisse par rapport à hier
je vous propose d'écouter le directeur
général de la santé en france
nous sommes face à une épidémie massive
meurtrière qui atteint un niveau inégalé
90 1676 cas confirmés ont été recensés
par santé publique france soit 4342 cas
de plus qui erre depuis le début de
l'épidémie depuis le 1er mars
on note 65 1420 hospitalisation ce qui
est vous confirme le poids considérable
de cette épidémie pour les
établissements de santé et surtout pour
nos professionnels de santé qui
travaillent sans relâche nuit et jour
sans jour désormais après la première
alerte en 24 heures ce sont trois mille
cent soixante et une nouvelle personne
qui ont été admises à l'hôpital cela
représente encore une hausse encore un
solde positif de 500 malades en plus
pour les établissements de santé par
rapport à hier cela vous démontre
l'activité la dynamique de cette
épidémie au cours des dernières 24
heures se sont donc 554 décès
supplémentaires qui ont été enregistrés
en milieu hospitalier et les personnels
soignants reste sur le front et comme
beaucoup d'établissements de santé les
cliniques privées sont elles aussi
mobilisés dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie
certaines ont dû réorganiser
tous leurs services comme à la clinique
ambroise paré à neuilly c'est en région
parisienne un reportage signé c'est el
farj et piotr sajas tu es derrière ces
murs de la clinique ambroise paré de
neuilly-sur-seine c'est tout un
écosystème qui a été entièrement
bouleversée pour affronter l'épidémie de
kovy de 19
julie et pharmaciens hospitaliers aux
côtés de julien elle doit notamment
anticiper et gérer les stocks de
médicaments
on a pu recevoir la quantité journalière
ce soir donc on va utiliser notre
réserve pouvoir fournir aux services
principal préoccupation pour les
pharmaciens à voir de l'avant sur les
stocks pour éviter qu'un médicament ne
vienne à manquer aujourd'hui on arrive
quand même à gérer le besoin au mieux
mais c'est vrai que c'est au prix de
grandes siège enfant sur le divan
molécules pour chaque patient pour
savoir exactement combien nous faut pour
la journée en fonction de ses besoins on
réadapte nous nous commande
delphine est infirmière à la clinique en
réanimation depuis dix ans cela fait un
mois que la jeune femme est entièrement
mobilisé pour le coronavirus pas
question pour elle de penser à la
fatigue et au stress t-rex et des
grosses journées où on compte pas les
heures c'est 12 13 heures de travail par
jour sur une semaine entière
mais après c'est à travailler donc on
est là pour ça la fatigue même si elle
est là et elle n'est pas là que pour moi
elle est là pour tous mes collègues
en fait on met ça de côté cool pour
répondre à cette crise sanitaire
nombreuses sont les personnels soignants
qui ont abandonné leur vie d'avant comme
alix d'habitude moi je suis au jeu franc
charge les patients qui se font opérer
du dos commence aussi et là on est on a
été réquisitionné pour pour le
la médecine cogite on était formée par
d'autres infirmières une journée et puis
ensuite nous mêmes ayant été formés ont
formé les autres 94 essais des patients
qui viennent des hôpitaux publics donc
bichat bourrier et du coup les on les
accueille ici pour désengorger des
hôpitaux publics
mise à part un seul étage tout la
clinique est aujourd'hui consacré aux
patients atteints du coc vite 19 d'un
service de réanimation avant la crise
sanitaire
la clinique en compte aujourd'hui 3 dans
ce couloir tout a été transformée aussi
à transformer les samples et à thouars
aurea réanimation c'est top et à toi
là-bas c'est quoi c'est des patients qui
viennent pour la journée pour des petits
de chirurgie d'accord donc
changer un service c'est quelques heures
d'après c'est énorme énorme fait un
travail colossal auquel participent
aussi des soignants venus d'ailleurs
paul est une jeune recrue
diplômé en juillet dernier le jeune
homme travaillait avant la crise dans un
autre établissement
ça change c'est la particularité de la
réanimation aussi faire ça a été court
du à l'urgence mais c'est vrai que vous
avez ils ont réussi à mettre toujours
des gens d'expérience pour qu'on soit
bien encadré et bien intégré malgré une
accalmie précaire constaté dans la
clinique
pas question pour tous et soignants de
baisser la garde ils le savent
la bataille continue avant son
allocution de lundi le président
emmanuel macron multiplie les réunions
avec les présidents de groupes
parlementaires les chefs de partis les
syndicats et le patronat aujourd'hui il
s'est entretenu avec plusieurs de ses
ministres avec les syndicats on va
revenir sur cette réunion avec benoît
martin secrétaire de l'union
départementale de la cgt paris benoît
martin merci d'accepter de répondre à
nos questions alors le chef de l'état
s'est donc entretenu on disait avec les
partenaires sociaux ce matin sur les
difficultés rencontrées par les salariés
quelques inquiétudes pour les salariés
ont partagé les syndicats avec le
président de la république
et bien en fait la délégation cgt a
surtout présenté ce qui était déjà dans
le contenu dans la lettre ouverte qui
avait été adressée au président de la
république par philippe martinez mardi
dernier donc le 7 avril
et donc voilà on a déjà on est parti de
cette contradiction fondamentale qui
perdure depuis déjà 24 jours 7
qu'en dire cette demande qui est fait à
la fois de rester confinés et d'aller
travailler et donc pour nous la société
premier point c'est qu'il ya deux trop
de gens sur leur lieu habituel de
travail aujourd'hui en france ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point qui a
été pointée par la délégation cgt
c'est là le recul du droit du travail
que l'on conteste ce n'est pas parce
qu'il ya une crise sanitaire qu'il faut
allonger la durée du travail est enlevée
d imposer en tout cas des jours de
congés payés aux salariés et puis on a
parlé également un petit peu du jour
d'après eux
voilà comment envoyer là en quoi cette
société française et une questions
planétaires également à comment les
sociétés humaines seraient modifiés
après cette crise extrêmement forte
alors pour vous les mesures de
protection à proposer sur les lieux de
travail ce n'est pas suffisant pour les
salariés alors ce n'est pas suffisant à
on a des remontées de terrain qui nous
font intervenir auprès des employeurs
parfois en associant les inspections du
travail la direction régionale de
l'emploi et du travail également
parfois en faisant intervenir la
préfecture et quand ce n'est pas
suffisant on fait également des
communiqués de presse anp on utilise
effectivement le relais médiatiques pour
faire connaître des situations et il
arrive même que la cgt ou d'autres
organisations syndicales et bien déposé
des plaintes auprès des juridictions
compétentes également alors qu'est ce
que vous demandez très concrètement pour
permettre aux salariés de traverser
cette crise le plus sereinement possible
eh bien on veut que ce soit au travail
sans lieu de travail habituel que les
salariés qui ont un rôle fondamental
dans forcément d'assembler la société
que ce soit le médical bien entendu que
ce soit la protection ad des citoyens
que ce soit le fait de nourrir les
citoyens et puis il aimait les services
publics fondamentaux tels que fournir de
de l'eau potable ramasser les poubelles
etc
gardez également les enfants des gens
que je viens de mentionner que ce soit
dans les écoles les crèches les centres
de loisirs notamment en ce moment en
cette période de congés scolaires dans
la série c est donc qu on veut que les
autres gens soient
chez eux confiné 1 pour ne pas répandre
à cette vie russe ne pas être vecteur de
la pandémie
et puis pour soulager les l'hôpital
public également donc qu'il y ait du
télétravail c'est une logique alors là
d'ailleurs les télétravailleurs ne sont
pas sans droit non plus mais il va il ya
aussi à peu près 6 millions de de
chômage parce de gens qui sont en
chômage partiel aujourd'hui ça pourrait
être au delà
par exemple aujourd'hui il ya des gens
qui travaillent dans des tp qui sont sur
des chantiers de construction qui n'ont
aucun caractère d'urgence et pour nous
ces gens là sont exposés à des dangers
et c'est extrêmement grave mais
justement sur cette question du chômage
partiel notamment avec toutes ces
dépenses à engager par le gouvernement
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que les
salariés seront appelés à prêts à faire
davantage d'efforts justement alors la
santé d'abord la fille sauver des vies
d'abord ensuite il faudra effectivement
relancer la machine économique il y aura
une quantité de travail importante mais
cherche souvent sans en un voilà il ne
va pas avoir une croissance positive
cette année on sait bien un peu partout
dans le monde il n'y aura pas que la
france donc une récession mais écoutez
il va falloir de toute manière après un
dea un plan de relance économique du
financement du travail de l'emploi pour
faire repartir la machine mais en ce
moment ce n'est pas le sujet principal
en ce moment c'est de sauver des vies de
soulager le personnel hospitalier et
puis aussi de enfin moi je suis comme
assez choqué que l'on découvre comme ça
avec beaucoup de retard le les chiffres
de de mordre dans les ehpad
pour moi il de enfin pour la sauge et il
devrait y avoir un tableau de bord
sanitaire concernant les ehpad et
concernant de la santé en général
qu'ils soient établis en permanence
n'est pas seulement essayé de le
construire en ce moment en rattrapage au
moment d'une crise
alors on le voit c'est le personnel
hospitalier qui est en première ligne
sur le front
depuis débute cette pandémie quelle est
votre regard là encore sur la gestion du
gouvernement par rapport à ce personnel
et bien il y a des des manquements de
taux très nettement un donc où la
pandémie est là donc la capacité
d'accueil dans les hôpitaux a été
augmentée il a fallu faire un peu d eau
quasiment des miracles pour vous pousser
les murs comme j'ai entendu l'expression
mais ceci dit ce n'est pas tout alors il
ya aussi du personnel de santé qui est
qui se proposait volontaires pour
renforcer les équipes d'autres ont été
réquisitionnés c'est assez logique mais
il manque du matériel il manque d'aidé
sur blues il manque en tous genres ces
fameux basque
il manque aussi dans les hôpitaux parfum
du curé d'autres médicaments acquis sont
nécessaires pour les hospitalisations
lourde pour la réanimation
donc voilà il ya un système de pénurie 1
donc la france le système français de
santé n'a pas été préparée à répondre à
cet événement qui est certainement
relativement rare mais qui était malgré
tout prévisible c'est logique que
parfois dans la vie il ya des des crises
des événements inattendus c'est pas des
catastrophes naturelles des catastrophes
industrielles
mais ça c'est aussi des épidémies merci
beaucoup benoît martin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire de l'union départementale de
la cgt paris et depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire certains députés ont
décidé de reprendre leur ancienne
activité professionnelle dans le milieu
médical afin de faire face à la vague
des deux malades dans les hôpitaux à ses
parlementaires de tous bords politiques
se mobilisent ils sont médecins
infirmiers ou encore aides soignants ils
ont été affectés à des postes dans les
établissements de santé service de samu
ou encore ehpad
comme caroline de fiat la députée de la
france insoumise elle a repris son
activité d'aide-soignante et elle se
sert de son expérience pour proposer
maintenant des pistes d'amélioration de
la situation des hôpitaux écoutez là
j'ai me servir de mon expérience pour
faire des propositions concrètes et
faire remonter les choses mais j'utilise
aussi ce
temps pour voir aussi les manques qui
peut y avoir et que j'avais plus trop
souvenir ça faisait trois ans que je
n'avais pas travaillé j'avais un peu
l'angoissé d'avoir perdu les bases mais
non c'est comme le vélo ça se perd pas
et j'ai utilisé effectivement tout ça
mais j'essaie de discuter avec les
collègues pour savoir quelle est leur
ressenti à eux aussi de ce qu'ils vivent
depuis trois ans à exactement
et depuis le début du confinement la
pression ne cesse de monter dans les
prisons françaises les détenus mais
aussi les gardiens ont souvent peur
d'une contamination due à la promiscuité
et à la vétusté des bâtiments à les
militants alerte sur les conditions
sanitaires de détention les agents
pénitentiaires ont le sentiment d'être
les oubliés de cette crise sanitaire
un reportage de mona mou dès lors et de
nicolas boisclair alors que les gars de
kobe 19 se multiplient en prison le
conseil d'état a rejeté de recours
visant à désengorger équipe et elle est
prise on les conditions de détention
continue de se dégrader impossible
d'appliquer est les gestes barrières et
de l'autre côté les agents
pénitentiaires craignent le pire un car
il manque de matériel pour travailler
dans de bonnes conditions
by mille détenus ont été libérés pour
désengorger les prisons qui reste en
surpopulation hauteur de 107% contre
119% avant la crise du coc vide
ce n'est pas assez pour françois corbère
juristes et délégué général de
l'association robin des lois qui milite
pour les droits des détenus
il ya beaucoup de personnes détenus en
détention provisoire qui vont sortir de
toute manière dans trois mois dans six
mois qui ne sont pas les personnes
dangereuses sur les ibères avec un
contrôle judiciaire
ils vont bien entendu à l'effet eux être
en confinement comme tout le monde ces
gens là on peut le libérer très
facilement on peut en libérer dhimmi
d'un seul coup en prison pas de gel et
de masques pour les détenus et les
gestes barrières sont inapplicables
la jeunesse que c'était une cellule en
sachant que vos voisins sont à même pas
1 mètre de vous et que n'importe lequel
d'entre eux peuvent vous contaminer avec
le virus l'hygiène dans la plupart des
prisons est détestable
parce que c'est pas que les directeurs
de prisons fassent leur boulot ils n'ont
pas les moyens
ils n'ont par laurence de savon le gel
de masques donc les personnes détenues
que nous avons au téléphone son estrade
en quête c'est normal après deux recours
rejetée par le conseil d'état
l'association a décidé de saisir la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et le
comité des droits de l'homme de l'onu
nous relançons fait appel notamment via
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qu'on a saisi il ya quelques jours et
l'onu le comité des droits de l'homme de
l'onu il ya une procédure d'urgence
on les appelle en iran au secours fait
quelque chose parce qu'il ya des
prisonniers qui vont nourrir les détenus
ne sont pas les seuls concernés par ces
recours rejeté à fleury mérogis les
agents pénitentiaires voit de plus en
plus leurs effectifs diminuer en raison
du virus
là j'ai un collègue voilà qui matent
écrit ce matin qu'il avait les symptômes
c'est à dire il a une forte fièvre
ils tous beaucoup et il appert il à la
perte du goût des agents qui ne peuvent
pas éviter le contact avec les détenus
en bois scooby secrétaire régional cgt
pénitentiaire tire la sonnette d'alarmé
le personnel est cruellement manque de
matériel au début on nous a pas donné de
masse au début aussi on a eu des
problèmes pour avoir ne serait-ce que le
minimum quand je parle de minimum c'est
les gels hydroalcooliques jeu pas de
minimum c'est des lingettes on avait du
mal à avoir ça et dans la détention où
je ne veux pas là en ile de france il ya
encore des détentions où on n'a pas ça
il y avait 86 cas avérés dans cette
prison a fleuri me résiste 86 cas mais
ça touche du surveillant au dictateur
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
le personnel est le sentiment de ne pas
être écoutés on nous oublié personne ne
parle de nous alors qu'il ya des morts
alors qu'il ya des souffrances alors
qu'il ya des agressions et ça continue
personne de nous n'est en sécurité parce
que l'extérieur on respire
mais dans la prison on est confiné et
c'est très dur
selon nicole belloubet la garde des
sceaux
de 200 mille masques de protection ont
été distribués au sein de
l'administration pénitentiaire des
mesures encore insuffisantes pour les
représentants syndicaux
et puis toujours à propos des prisons le
conseil d'état a rejeté un recours il
demandait d'accorder des masques et des
tests et du gel hydroalcoolique à tous
les détenus
le juge des référés au conseil d'état a
estimé que les mesures déjà prises et
celles annoncées par le gouvernement
permettait de réduire le risque de
contamination au sein des prisons plus
d'informations et les témoignages
exclusifs de prisonniers et de gardiens
à retrouver sur notre site
rt france.fr les méthodes de
surveillance du confinement remise en
question depuis plusieurs semaines les
forces de l'ordre utilisent des drones
pour surveiller les déplacements de la
population alors que la france entière
est confiné une réglementation précise
encadrent lé usage de ces appareils
et malgré cela un flou persiste autour
de cette pratique à certains évoquent un
vide juridique à thierry vallat est
avocat au bureau de paris il nous
précise le cadre dans lequel
l'utilisation des drones est possible
d'écouter 9
la france a été un des premiers pays à
mettre en place d'une réglementation sur
les drones et aujourd'hui la
réglementation applicable par une boîte
de 100 celle de 2016 c'est un arrêté de
2015 et sur le fondement de cet arrêté
de 2015
les forces de l'ordre ont la possibilité
d'utiliser en dérogation aux règles
normales d'utilisation d'un drone au
dessus d'une foule ou de surveillance
des personnes auront tout à fait la
possibilité de déroger à cette
interdiction pour utiliser à des fins de
protection civile
là les drones donc ces aéronefs sans
personne à bord
donc pour des fins de qui sont
complètement compatibles avec celles qui
leur sont assumés aujourd'hui par là par
la crise la crise du corona virus alors
le drone va servir d'appui aux forces au
sol
le drone va servir à identifier
quelqu'un qui est or dans une zone
interdite et là on va avoir une brigade
d'aidé gendarmes ou des policiers qui
vont venir cueillir le contrevenant est
là lui mettre une lui mettre la
contravention
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
fait part de ses craintes concernant ab
confinement prématuré le dire
général de l'institution onusienne
redoute des conséquences désastreuses
écoutez le comme tout le monde
l'om est sèmerait voir les restriction
levée en même temps lever les
restrictions trop rapidement pourrait
entraîner une résurgence mortels le
reflux pourrait être aussi mortel que sa
propagation s'il n'était pas gérée
convenablement
l'om est ce travail avec les pays
touchés sur des stratégies visant à
lever progressivement et en toute
sécurité les restrictions 500 milliards
d'euros pour relancer l'économie de
l'union européenne c'est l'accord trouvé
lien entre les ministres des finances
européens après plusieurs jours de
discussions infructueuses un sommet de
l'union européenne aura lieu le 23 avril
pour je cite jeter les bases d'une
reprise économique robuste un plan en
trois axes est prévu jusqu'à 240
milliards d'euros de prêts du fonds de
secours de la zone euro
un fonds de garantie de 200 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises
et puis jusqu'à 100 milliards pour
soutenir le chômage partiel ces
propositions des ministres doivent
encore être approuvé par les chefs de
l'état et de gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous avons convenu de trois
filets de sécurité d'un plan de relance
pour garantir que nous nous développions
ensemble et non séparément
une fois le virus derrière nous le
projet que nous avons approuvé
aujourd'hui représente 4% du pib
européen avec les stabilisateurs
automatiques qui sont assez puissants
pour protéger les économies européennes
en cas de crise c'est totalement son
précédent nous n'avons jamais réagi
aussi rapidement une crise comme celle
qui est selon le dernier bilan publié ce
vendredi
la belgique vient de passer la barre
symbolique des 3000 morts quatre cent
quatre-vingt seize nouveaux décès ont
été recensés au cours des dernières 24
heures portant le total à 3019 morts
depuis le début de l'épidémie le nombre
de décès a triplé en trois jours avec
l'ajout du nombre de morts en maison de
retraite
l approche des fêtes de pâques les
autorités sanitaires ont appelé les
belges à rester chez eux à mercredi
prochain le gouvernement doit décider de
la prolongation ou pas dû
finement et puis au royaume-uni boris
johnson contaminée par le coronavirus
est sorti hier soir des soins intensifs
le premier ministre britannique est
toujours hospitalisée sous surveillance
pendant la phase initiale de sa guérison
selon son cabinet face à l'aggravation
de la situation dans le pays le
gouvernement a prévenu qu'il fallait se
préparer à une prolongation du
confinement
le dernier bilan fait état de 9 181
décès supplémentaires soit un total de
huit 1958 depuis le début de l'épidémie
et puis lueur d'espoir en espagne le
pays a enregistré 6 105 morts en 24
heures soit le total le plus faible
depuis le 24 mars l espagne reste l'un
des pays les plus touchés par la
pandémie avec 15 1843 victimes du
coronavirus le confinement de la
population a été prolongé jusqu'au 25
avril après une suspension des activités
économiques non essentiel pendant quinze
jours
les entreprises pourront réouvrir lundi
elle démasque seront distribués en lundi
en espagne notamment dans les transports
en commun
pourtant doit partir à partir de lundi
prochain dans certaines parties du
territoire espagnol et dans d'autres non
parce que lundi est un jour férié les
entreprises dont le travail avait été
autorisé par décret peuvent reprendre
leurs activités
nous allons distribuer des masques
d'hygiène dans certains endroits comme
les stations de métro station de train
de banlieue à différents points où en
raison des caractéristiques que j'ai
défini son utilisation est recommandée
la direction l'italie maintenant pays le
plus durement frappé par cette pandémie
plus de 18000 personnes sont décédées du
coït 19 conséquence les italiens
resteront confinées jusqu'au 3 mai a
annoncé le gouvernement en première
ligne dans cette crise le personnel de
santé depuis le début de l'épidémie une
centaine de médecins sont décédés après
avoir été contaminés par le virus jordi
demory ils sont en première ligne face
au co vie 19 en italie pays européens
qui comptent le plus grand nombre de
morts le personnel soignant payent un
lourd tribut depuis le début de
l'épidémie
une centaine de docteurs sont décédés du
coronavirus
sur place leurs confrères dénonce le peu
d'équipement de protection mises à leur
disposition
nous croyons que le manque d'équipements
de protection individuelle médical et
les problèmes d'approvisionnement sont
sans aucun doute liés aux taux
d'infection élevé et à certains des
décès que nous avons constaté depuis
début mars certains médecins italiens ne
cesse d'alerter notamment sur le manque
de masque une situation qui commence à
peine à s'améliorer
le problème du manque d'équipements de
protection individuelle est également un
problème au niveau institutionnel
provoqué par un tsunami de cas qui nous
a frappés a tout bouleversé
nous nous sommes retrouvés en état de
guerre munis d'armes inadéquate
notamment un nombre limité de masques
progressivement les masques deviennent
disponibles
par ailleurs à la place des masques
chirurgicaux les gens pourraient porter
des écharpes ou utiliser d'autres choses
afin de réduire l'émission de
gouttelettes
certes cette alternative serait moins
efficace par rapport aux masques
chirurgicaux mais elle peut être
utilisée
cela doit nous motiver à maintenir cette
distanciation sociale comme dans de
nombreux pays le personnel soignant ne
compte pas ses heures
mais en plus de soigner les malades ils
passent énormément de temps à s'équiper
et à ceux des contaminés nous avons
estimé que pour un travail de 7 heures
environ 40 50 minutes sont utilisés rien
que pour l'habillage externe est tel
point que les world and gas shale à
vagues générées manuel pour ce qui est
du lavage des mains et la
décontamination des mains on peut parler
de 60 75 minutes par jour communauté
narquois toujours lourdement touché
l'italie continue de recevoir de l'aide
venus du monde entier
ce mercredi un avion de l'armée de l'air
du qatar est arrivé avec du matériel
pour construire deux hôpitaux de
campagne à rome et à vérone et on s'en
va aux états unis où le bilan est encore
plus lourd de jour en jour 460 mille cas
ont été confirmés à ce jour est déjà
plus de 16 mille quatre cents morts hier
plus de 1700 personnes
morts en 24 heures un bilan toutefois
inférieur à celui de la veille
en revanche l'état de new york principal
foyer de l'épidémie américaine
enregistre une nouvelle progression
record 800 morts en 24 heures et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci l'avoir
suivi prochain point sur l'actualité
dans un peu plus de trente minutes
restez avec nous sur rt français total
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous